we're wrong we're gonna figure that out
okay let's go direct right here to four
can I do that what's up with that
Oh what's up or is it 3 2 yeah we'll go
to 2 all 2 is 1 now hi everybody welcome
to the show this is simulation series
I'm Ron Vargas what's up what's up and
there's Alan's akheon over there oh
there's the credits again I gotta shoot
this off alright let's come over there
and do this
whoops there's the credits again mmm
yeah we're really figuring out how to
best use this technology you've got a
little quad of you going on right there
that's kind of cool yes that's right
right now Alan and I were just talking
and there I am over there and I thought
it would be best to just capture this we
should you know which I'm ready to just
put these conversations available to
people trying to work something out
exactly and is this my water yes that's
your water also what's the live shot to
the program for what for is in the top
right right
no often they're watching the author or
angles right now i mean i can switch
switch let's do that
i did i or what happened
ah the saw keyboard is not connected
whatever hey whatever well we got the
quad we got you got views you from all
different angles which is cool yeah
let's do that
right um because we're also trying to
figure out how to bring the keyboard
over here to use it for mixed effects
purposes or the iPad the iPad we have
they were supposed to be able to with
the TriCaster that we use this tc1
NewTek TriCaster how much was it $19,000
right and let's we don't want to get
into that right now we're not gonna get
into that but it will be cool to have
the iPad software just to be able to sit
here and switch between cameras on them
on the live feed I wonder if it's okay
but but let's um
yeah something something weren't went up
with the keyboard we'll just leave you
guys at the quad view Ron and I have
have a very interesting dynamic between
each other we got like like Ron's like
an older brother to me again sometimes
also be like my dad at time is really
really spiritual but also wise it's it's
it's it's fun to to have Ron as the
director and producer of the show it's
fun to be working for you with that
being weird and sorry to interrupt I
know you want to say your piece but it's
I just can't help but interject did you
correct my English is well I just said
with it's nice to work with work with
you we have a really good amount of
guests that are coming on the show that
Ron's been enjoying sometimes we have
guests that Ron don't it doesn't enjoy
that as much was it that I didn't enjoy
do you want to are there really it's
been a great mix of gasoline you've had
on your show if anybody you know if any
of my my my my my close friends aren't
our watching this right now I'm working
on this program with Alan sake and right
here Alan socking we got all these
daughters there yes over there but it's
uh it's it's it's good it's good we got
a lot of work to do to make a puncher
and catchy ER and faster and funner
funner we got to make it fun but you
know we met him with three comedians in
his show I met him and we've yet to have
who if we had in the comics on you Rico
why can't we you know what about Eureka
well we already brought we will we had a
we have a clips of Eureka let's you know
what's in the link of Eureka we the show
the science the science comedy show that
you know we're gonna do something else
somewhat somewhat similar to something
like that don't like we had some
comedians that were gonna come on the
show that had to back out because of
some family issues but we will get some
comics on the show as well just because
it's fun to sit down with comedians do
ya you get back to you yeah so we'll
explore the comedian's thing so Ron and
I really wanted to keep this live stream
focused on our dynamic because we think
that there's a lot of people that are
going through relationships with
partners with like a business partner
with a with someone that they work with
on a daily basis that they have some
sort of both like you know positive
relate a lot of positive relationships
with but also like a couple like you
know there's there's some like
negativities as well communication we
were talking about communication between
partners and any aspect and this whole
thing the next like 20 minutes of us
talking about this is just gonna be is
it gonna be 20 minutes let's let's do
they do the hourglass will flip the
hourglass for now so so that's what
we're gonna talk about right now so
let's just launch into the thing that we
were talking about when we be mindful we
have very little time if we can't
discuss if we can't resolve we gotta
move on just yeah we'll do another
episode talking about this but but the
thing that we were just talking about
like Ron and I you know we need to sit
down and we need to talk more we need to
get in each other's heart energy more we
need to like what else are we talking
about when we when we sat down when we
first sat down and you were like let's
communication yesterday you mentioned
throwing when you communicate
don't throw people into the abyss like
my communication may be sometimes a
little aggressive or a little passionate
I'll raise my voice and that's would
tend to throw people into the abyss or
I'll just you know totally alter
whatever we was ahead to just
deal with it and in that way so my
content my communication as we were
talking with us turday where I assumed I
was throwing you into the abyss and
that's where I decided well let's record
this let's let's capture this discussion
talk about how you want me to
communicate with you how you want me to
do my job do what I'm supposed to do
continue to be your [ __ ] bestie and
but get [ __ ] done
how do
want me to communicate you want a hug
you want a hug Alan let me give you a
hug let's make you're in the shot -
there we go and we can go over there we
can give each other a hug all right now
get out of the air see that's what we
can't there's no time to let a hug is
good but then you have to they don't
want to take advantage of that I've been
looking right sure but so I do follow up
on what you just said so you just said
that it was like the abyss and the
communication that's really important to
touch on as we talk about this so it's
not even that like I want you to be my
bestie it's more like if you really
truly see the potential of these massive
live events inside of football stadiums
where 50,000 people are all spending an
hour learning about biotech an hour
learning about blockchain an hour
learning about geopolitics an hour
learning about AI and robotics and
they're spending these hour long chunks
in these all immersive experience design
with different gizmos and gadgets but if
I see that in a convention later more so
that doesn't exist in a Convention
Center like there's nothing in the world
like that nothing in the world is quite
like that there's no football it's when
you say in this vision I think of them
film the Warriors in left and the guy
saying 'die going against another 11
football players and instead of there
being 22 football players on the field
there's a big stage and then there's
scientists and entrepreneurs that come
and sit on the stage five at a time
that talk to 50,000 people sitting
around them and then they're all opening
up different parts of their bag that
have these different aspects of what
they're communicating and teaching about
that does not exist and then also so
it's not about being a bestie it's more
like do you think that this vision has
the potential to be one of the coolest
most game-changing visions because if
that's the case great if it's not then
you you didn't you that's when you talk
to me about like okay what is your
alignment then if there is not enough
alignment with what we're doing then you
know that
got to figure out like well who should
be a director producer for the show then
instead of you you know so like like
that's just a total truth about it's not
about like being lashed on or attached
on to to one another yeah so like if the
visions got to work out and we're not
just doing one show this is not one show
for the next ten years this is one show
and we rarely get to do Fried Chicken in
between we're gonna bring a comedian on
to the show soon so like we're slowly
creeping into doing other [ __ ] and
eventually in a couple months once this
is a more sustainable entity we will
have totally other productions going on
that are that are fascinating like other
people come in and use our studio we
have like everyone not everyone we have
only a couple people that are interested
in using our studio space and so we do
produce shows for other people we had
Sonny Jane in from son genomics and he
came in he's a patron he wanted to do
sessions that was fun so it's like a too
long yeah not too long it's fun we have
some graphics we you know we played with
and we learned about the microbiome and
so you know we got these slow slow but
surely were not only doing simulation
we're doing other important productions
coming along and like if you're
interested in doing all these
productions including your ideas and if
you're also excited about this 50,000
seat
events then like then let's do that
right and but if you're but if you can't
like get into that then you know get
into whatever you care about them so
like that's it
and like regarding communication like
I'm not I'm not saying oh like you tell
me how you want to talk to me or how I
should talk to you you know it's
actually not like force it onto me it's
more like can I just like explain a
story that hopefully makes you feel and
understand what I'm going through so
that way then
you are more sensitive to the way that
you're behaving and causing me stress or
anxiety or negative feelings because
like yeah yesterday was it was like a
couple like you know very like like you
know like you know difficult to math
like difficult message points to deal
with and like you know it's um and like
it's a lot easier for me to like reply
you know I forgot to update that one of
our guests had canceled because they
literally told me that morning that they
canceled and then you know like and you
were like you know basically in a mood
of like being pissed off and said for
not actually triggered I was actually
enjoying myself until things just
started you know I was finished there
and I was coming back to simulation this
vision and that's that's the [ __ ] that I
had to deal with just that you know
whatever there's a lot of these there's
like there's thanks for you know you not
didn't update him not for the other
update that I didn't send you a cost of
me still having a chip into the overall
you want me to work and and also pay for
it and then it's just it's just
interesting okay you know you have done
your skin so complicated dresses the
pays a little complicated because we got
the equipment sold the old equipment and
then our using equipment at events and
we Selene you figure out exactly how
much we want to charge for just a unit
and how much you need to charge for just
the director and producer pay and we
need to figure all that out and we're
going to a speculum this Empire that you
want to build an empire the 50 costs a
lot of money to put fifty thousand
people and a [ __ ] Levi Stadium
you're dealing with the millions of
dollars okay so you know right now we're
charge is trying to pay rent I mean you
want me to focus on this vision and how
do we get there oh really how do we all
really that's big you know well it's
doable but that's goes those are that's
a big that's a big vision a lever you
call it like yeah that's a big vision
you call it an empire you don't say it
in a loving way you call you like you
you make me feel like I'm a disgusting
person when you say that's what I'm
trying to get communicate to you you
don't feel like that well why don't I
explain why like when you message me
these things you you you know and cut me
out of this or not okay then just get
your [ __ ] together I didn't want to hang
with you I just didn't want to hang with
but I'm just you know I'm not going
besties there am i right and so my don't
rub my my mind is racing and it's
thinking like as a reply to you is like
you know for you going you know [ __ ] you
for this [ __ ] you for this [ __ ] you for
this awesome I was at home then I said
[ __ ] you no he did not say once [ __ ] me
but he made me feel like that was coming
out of his mouth and then what I was
manifesting in my mind in return was
like well what if I was just like [ __ ]
you for this book you for that in return
and I did not do that because it's super
detrimental to do that yeah so and so I
replied by saying lovey Ronnie I'll keep
working on everything you listed above
have a good night and so my point is
that when you say things like Empire and
when you say things like you know I'm
listening to you I'm listening to you
and you're moving around and doing other
things in the site don't you believe
that it's not that I don't believe that
you are it's that I understand
neuroscience and you are not giving me
your full attention how do you know I
can't multitask like that though I'm
simply here when I say that every human
can multitask but it means you're
dedicating cognitive resources to
something else and not giving me a
hundred percent humans when they're
having serious conversations like right
now you're not I'm gonna get some truth
of what I'm saying I'm gonna get some
fruit or something I just want that we
could get some fruit did you eat all the
strawberries it's like sometimes it's
like keep there yeah yeah I keep are
chilled or the conversation gets for you
to have the more you'll want to like go
get fruit or something instead of just
like sit down and talk about it we only
like the 15-minute timer is that like
just cut three I'm listening to you
you're talking about the
a minute I marry strawberries and come
over cuz like the timer is almost done
we're gonna cut this off anyway in just
like a couple minutes so just sit down
you know and like don't derail us from
finishing that thought thank you like
you can eat up because you wanted them
one night it I already ate like 17 so
think seriously like if if there is a
conversational point like look like
you're not even looking at me right now
you know seriously what making came in
but you do the same thing you're like
look at me right humans want to be
looked at because they want to feel like
the other person's giving them their
full attention like then you get my full
attention are you right here I'm with
you with you right now how can I
possibly avoid it if I'm listening to
you Ron no I'm not I'm looking at other
[ __ ] thinking about other [ __ ] so
alright now that we're on the same token
you're in the fum in the [ __ ] room
with you
right here right now what what's wrong
with looking at each other we're gonna
finally get to communication awesome so
we're finally getting the communication
now alright
so with all that messaging that happened
at any time the person can just flick
flip at the at the other one and just go
negative negative negative until someone
says something positive once someone
says something positive then the other
person can't reply with a negative it
doesn't work like that so typically what
ends up happening is one person has to
nut up has to be the better person and
not be a douchebag that's when you did
yesterday and that's why I love you Alan
and what's wrong with that
well it doesn't makes because it's
better for the whole collective as RAK
was just sitting here and talking about
you were living in ego instead of we go
like if you were living in we go that
message that you drafted to me would it
be different it would be like hey like
I'm not gonna go to Half Moon Bay
because of this and I think that the way
that you're scheduling events is you
know you need to cancel them on time so
that we don't have this
and like there's a whole different way
to say it with and you haven't even I
ran a case study to see if the person's
gonna reply in a positive way to you
when you talk to them in that way they
study immediately jumping to the
negative way of communication thinking
that that's the only in best way is not
really true like to feel you've seen me
communicate in different ways you see me
take a whole different approach on stuff
that bothers me you know there's a I'm
aware I don't think you have yet like to
something that you really don't like to
like really have diplomatically get my
point across to where we can know yeah
something's got in that hardly my doing
as well as that I need to be more
receptive to you trying to be more
diplomatic in the way that you're
approaching things but like you got to
actually give it a shot like you got to
give positivity a shot in that text your
draft I don't wish to say these they
have positive these on part this isn't
positive it's positive for me yeah but
it's positive for you because you're
taking what emotions you have inside and
you're just going Krang to the other
person and the other person I wish had a
cape and a whip yeah I'm [ __ ] my eyes
turned red I'm like that's great for you
because you get this you get that
feeling and the person on the other end
gets a feeling of [ __ ] and that person
has to do a [ __ ] in their mind listen
other percents anymore in their mind for
sometimes an hour they have to dwell on
this thought of like does this person
actually like love me because or like me
even because of the way that they're
messaging me because right now it sure
does seem like they could couldn't give
two [ __ ] about the way that I feel
because they'll just message me whatever
the [ __ ] they feel like versus the way
that I carefully craft messages to make
sure that you know that I at least liked
or loved you versus making it feel like
all right 15 minute time results so
that's been a little short segment into
the way that Allen and Ron are trying to
develop and grow as humans and ask
relationship as producers of this show
and many more to come
are we gonna continue talking about this
when we end the show well I was thinking
about anything right now do you have
another topic you want to talk about
before we end it communicate is harder
we'll keep learning over time you want
to go another 15 that's 15 minutes well
I just flipped it just so we could we
share we should that we should argue at
least be ready to interact with the
audience in case that if somebody wanted
to throw in their two cents
if we did a show like this you know they
people people could help yeah well yeah
we'll work on it I mean I can go pull up
the live stream right now and go see if
anyone's saying anything but yeah or if
anybody's watching yeah can you see it
on your phone can you see live text on
your phone I'm not sure if you can are
you doing at the comments right now
there I am
can I see it can I look at it well I'm
trying to look at the comments let me
see it comments are not supported on
private videos damn it I forget here at
NASA they are on Facebook I for know I
forgot to move that Iraq razzle video is
also at 0 views because why because it's
a private I didn't ah they got us you
got me good Alan alright we love you
thank you this is a lot of fun now we're
gonna make this play let's chill top so
we can get a hug and we'll do a zoom out
and there we go and get a hug and then
we'll have good a good idea goodnight
viewers where the bells down over there
the best yeah bye everyone we love you
let's fade to black
let's just fade to black and end this
show